Guten Abend, ich bin der Diensthabende Arzt auf der Station und werde mit Ihnen Aufnahmegesprache führen.
Sind Sie damit verstanden?
Ja, sicher, natürlich.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Albert Lärm.
Albert Lärm.
Lärm, A-H-M-Giebel.
Okay, L-A-H-M.
Genau.
Und wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Ich bin 47 Jahre alt, bin geboren am 14.06.75.
Herr Lärm, Sie sind 47 Jahre alt.
Genau.
Richtig zwischen den Hörn.
Und wie groß sind Sie, Herr Lärm?
Ich bin 1,75 Meter.
Okay.
Wie viel wiegen Sie, wenn ich vorhin darf, Herr Lärm?
Ich wiege jetzt 80 Kilo.
80 Kilo.
Alles klar.
Also, wie kann ich Ihnen helfen,
wenn ich mit Maskelefilizierung herla?
Ja, also wissen Sie,
mir geht es eigentlich seit Wochen jetzt schlecht.
Ich erkenne mich selber nicht wieder.
Entschuldigung, Herr Lärm, ich konnte den Akustik nicht verstanden.
Können Sie bitte wiederholen?
Ja, seit einigen Monaten fühle ich mich schlecht.
Ich fühle mich so gebrenzt.
Ich habe überhaupt gar keine Lust, irgendwas zu arbeiten.
Ich fühle mich auch so körperlich schwach.
Ich merke, dass wenn ich die Treppe hochlaufe,
das fällt mir schwer.
Ich habe überhaupt keine Lust, rauszugehen
und auch an die Arbeit zu gehen
oder etwas im Garten zu arbeiten.
Und so kenne ich mich überhaupt gar nicht.
Das wird halt immer schlimmer.
Ja, verstehe, Herr Lärm.
Haben Sie noch irgendwelche Beschwerden haben,
wie schwindelig Übelkeit oder solche Gymphtomen?
Schwindel habe ich eigentlich nicht.
Was mir aufgefallen ist, dass ich immer friere
und gerade diese zunehmende Kälte,
da komme ich überhaupt nicht mit zurecht.
Was mir aufgefallen ist,
dass mir mein Gesicht so anspült
und auch die Füsse schwellen an.
Haben Sie gänzehaut?
Ja, bitte schon.
Geschwollenes Gesicht
und am Abend oder am Übertag
schwellen mir die Füsse an.
Herr Lärm, haben Sie auch verschwommen, wenn Sie es sehen?
Schlecht sehen? Kann ich nicht.
Das habe ich keine Probleme eigentlich.
Kein Problem.
Haben Sie irgendwelche woanders beim Herz bemerkt?
Beim Herz?
Ja, genau.
Rhythmstorien?
Das ist mir jetzt nicht aufgefallen.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Atemproblemen?
Atemnot?
Müssen Sie Schlafpause machen?
Nein, sowas eigentlich nicht.
Ich bin nur, ich bin nur,
ja, man würde fast sagen, wie ein Fault hier.
Ich komme langsam in die Gänge
und ich bin müde
und ich schlafe so schnell ein,
wenn ich irgendwo sitze und moment warten muss.
Ja, verstehe.
Im Sommerzeit
müssen Sie wärmerkleidung anziehen.
Ich bin nur, ich bin nur,
Wärmekleidung anziehen.
Haben Sie solche Beschwerden?
Ja, ganz so schlimm.
Ganz so schlimm nicht.
Aber jetzt mit zunehmender Kühlerwitterung
merke ich, dass ich das überhaupt nicht haben kann,
dass ich mich sehr warm anziehen muss.
Ja, verstehe.
Haben Sie noch irgendwelche
Krankungen wie zum Beispiel
Zuckerkrankheit oder Blutrochtung?
Nee, das habe ich nicht.
Was bekannt ist, dass ich ein bisschen
so eine so eine
Schlafabne habe. Ich habe Polyken in der Nase
und deswegen schlafe ich.
Hab ich so Atemaussetzer in der Nacht.
Ich habe mal eine Zeit lang solche solche
Maske getragen in der Nacht, damit ich
versiert atme.
Aber ja, das ist mir jetzt auch alles zu lästig.
Da kann ich auch nicht so gut mit schlafen.
Und deswegen habe ich das wieder sein gelassen.
Seit wann brauchen Sie dieses Gerat?
Ach, das habe ich
verschrieben bekommen schon vor ein paar Jahren.
Aber ich benutze es gar nicht mehr, weil mir das so lästig ist.
Ah, okay.
Alles klar. Verstehe.
Herr Lam, haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen
oder Stuhlgang?
Wie zum Beispiel bei Wasserlärmung?
Nicht, aber aber ich bin immer verstopft.
Verstöpfe.
Okay, verstehe.
Nehmen Sie irgendwelche Medikamente oder Saft dagegen?
Ja, ich nehme so Laktolose, Sirup.
Hat hat das Ihnen geholfen?
Das bringt dann ein bisschen, ich nehme das halt bei,
bitte auf.
Herr Lam, Sie haben schon gesagt, dass Sie können nicht
so lange Strecke laufen.
Sie müssen immer Pause machen.
Wie lange können Sie laufen?
Ach,
ich kann schon Kilometer gehen, aber es ist halt
mühselig so.
Ah, okay.
Aber man muss langsam verstehen.
Ja, also ich merke, dass mir das früher viel leichter
gefallen ist und jetzt fällt es mir sehr schwer.
Okay.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Ausschlösser bemerkt für diese Beschwerden?
Nein, das kann ich gar nicht sagen.
Das hat sich so angeschlichen, das ist immer schlechter geworden.
Okay.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Schluckprobleme?
Im Hals?
Nein, nein.
Eigentlich so richtige, wie bei Halsschmerzen oder so
Stuckprobleme habe ich nicht.
Nein.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Schwellung bemerkt im Hals?
Ist mir nicht aufgefallen, aber ich habe auch nicht so
drauf geachtet.
Aber wo Sie sagen Schwellung, also, was mir aufgefallen
ist, ich habe in den letzten paar Monaten ordentlich
zugenommen, obwohl ich eigentlich gar nicht,
ich habe gar nicht das Gefühl gehabt, dass ich so viel mehr
gegessen habe.
Aber ich habe vier Kilo zugenommen.
Im letzten Mal.
Was meinen Sie genau in den letzten Seiten?
In drei Monaten?
Ja, ungefähr so in drei Monaten.
Okay.
Herr Lohm, nehmen Sie irgendwelche Medikamente
regelmäßig ein?
Nee, regelmäßig eigentlich gar nichts.
Was ich regelmäßig benutze, ich habe so ein
Exem am Kopf, so eine Schuppenbildung, und dann
nehme ich immer so ein Spezial-Champo,
Ketogien-Champo.
Aber das ist das Einzige, was ich regelmäßig benutze
und alles andere nehme ich nur, also irgendwas
gegen Kopfschmerzen, zum Beispiel nehme ich mal
Aspirin oder eben diesen lachzulose Syrup, wenn ich
merke, dass ich nicht zur Toilette kann.
Okay.
Haben Sie oft diese Kopfschmerzen oder selten
gelegentlich?
Ja, also wenn ich viel am Schreibtisch gesessen
habe, dann habe ich so vom Nacken aus geht,
oft Kopfschmerzen.
Okay, verstehe.
Was machen Sie dann beruflich?
Ich arbeite in der Forstverwaltung.
Wie bitte?
In der Forstverwaltung.
Wir sind also zuständig für die Wälder,
für die Wälder in unserem Bundesland und
das muss halt ja auch alles verwaltet werden.
Und da bin ich tätig.
Wer das, das Sie, oder?
Nein, eigentlich ist das ein interessanter Job.
Manchmal habe ich auch Außentermine,
aber bei den Außenterminen merke ich das
jetzt eben auch, wenn ich mit dem Auto
unterwegs bin, dass ich sozusagen Einschlafe
am Steuer haben.
Da muss ich mich mit Mühe wachhalten.
Ja, verstehe.
Ja, haben Sie irgendwelche Schwellung
in Ihrer Beine?
Ja, an den Füßen.
Das hatte ich gleich am Anfang gesagt, ja,
dass ich so am übertaggeschwollene
Füße habe.
Okay.
So, Herr Lam, wo denn Sie schon mal operiert?
Eine richtige Operation habe ich eigentlich noch nicht gehabt.
Nein.
Rauchen Sie?
Nein, seit neun Jahren rauche ich nicht mehr,
aber davor habe ich mal eine Weile
gut geraucht. Ja.
Können Sie etwas Nährres erzählen davon?
Ja, also, ich denke mal so, 20 Jahre lang,
20 Jahre lang habe ich ein Täckchen am Tag geraucht.
Wie viel Schachtel am Tag? Entschuldigung.
Eine Packung am Tag.
Okay. Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Alkohol, also ich trinke regelmäßig abends
ein bis zwei Flaschen via.
Ein bis zwei, okay.
Herr Lam, bitte nehmen Sie meine jetzige Frage
nicht persönlich.
Das ist eine Routine Frage, das muss ich Ihnen stillen.
Haben Sie schon einmal irgendwann in Ihrem Leben
mit Drogen etwas Erfahrung?
Mit Drogen-Erfahrung? Nein, da habe ich überhaupt keine Erfahrung.
Okay, das ist gut.
Haben Sie Allergie?
Ja, ich habe eine Allergie auf Pferdehaare.
Pferdehaare?
Und dann bin ich auch empfindlich auf ein Medikament
auf die Klofinak.
Bei beiden kriege ich also einen Hautausschlag
und deswegen muss ich da ein bisschen vorsichtig sein.
Pferdhaare kann ein bisschen im Wälder Schwierigkeit bringen.
Ist das so oder?
Pferdhaare, haben Sie schon gesagt.
Sie reagieren allergisch gegen Pferdhaare.
Pferdehaare, ja.
Und ich arbeite in der Postverwaltung.
Genau, das ist auch aufgefallen.
Ich arbeite eigentlich überwiegend im Innenbereich,
also im Verwaltungsbereich, aber bei den Außenterminen,
da hat man das auch festgestellt, dass ich da darauf allergisch bin.
Nehmen Sie irgendwelche Medikamente dagegen?
Nein, ich gehe aus dem Weg und dann ist es gut.
Okay, alles ging gut.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft auch gegen Corona?
Gegen Corona bin ich vollständig geimpft.
Ja, also dreimal.
Und gegen Kinderkrankheit?
Ja, seinerzeit bin ich natürlich gegen alles geimpft worden.
Ob jetzt da alles auf dem aktuellen Stand ist,
aber ich glaube, dass ich da ziemlich gut versorgt bin.
Ja, super.
Herr Lam, sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Okay, haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ich habe ein Kind, ja.
Ein Kind.
Ist es auch gesund?
Mein Sohn ist gesund, ja, ja, zum Glück.
Ja, super.
Sie leben zusammen, oder?
Wir leben in der Familie zusammen, ja, ja, klar.
Ja, super, das ist gut.
Und ist Ihre Frau irgendwelche Veränderungen von Ihnen bemerkt?
Ja, die sagst du natürlich auch.
Ja, meine Frau sagt auch, also mein Gott, was ist denn los mit dir?
Geh doch mal zum Arzt, du bist so lahm und kommst gar nicht,
kommst gar nicht in Gang und immer muss man alles fünfmal sagen,
damit etwas passiert.
Eigentlich hat sie mich so ein bisschen geschubst,
dass ich zum Arzt gehe.
Ja, verstehe.
Gut.
Herr Lam, ich denke, ich habe schon meine Frau,
meine alle wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen?
Ach eigentlich weiß ich jetzt gar nicht, was ich Ihnen noch erzählen könnte.
Also ich habe Ihnen ja geschildert, wie mein Problem ist.
Jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, was, was kann man dagegen machen,
woran lichten das?
Ja, bis jetztige Angaben habe ich natürlich eine Vermutung.
Möglicherweise haben Sie eine Schilderöseunterfunktion.
Aber müssen wir sehr sein mit Laboruntersuchungen
und körperliche Untersuchungen.
Ich kann jetzt so sagen.
Okay.
Das war es von meiner Seite.
Ah, Entschuldigung.
Vielen Dank Herr Kollege.
Leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Mein Vater lebt noch, aber meine Mutter ist vor gar nicht langer Zeit
verstorben.
Woran ist sie gestorben, wenn ich fragen darf?
Die hatte, die hatte ein akutes Herz,
die hatte eine akute Herz, die hatte eine akute Herz.
Das war es von meiner Seite.
Ja, das war es von meiner Seite.
Die hatte, die hatte ein akutes Herz,
ein Herzstillstand hat der Arzt gesagt.
Also eigentlich war da nichts bekannt,
dass die irgendwie schwer krank ist.
Und ja, wahrscheinlich hat sie heimlich still und leise
irgendwie so eine Herzkrankheit entwickelt.
Aber ja gut, sie war jetzt auch nicht mehr jung.
Die war jetzt auch schon deutlich über 70.
Und ja.
Ja.
Aber mein Vater lebt noch.
Hat Ihr Vater irgendwelche Erkrankungen?
Ja, der hat tatsächlich so eine ein bisschen
besonderbare Erkrankung.
Der hat eine Nebennieren-Schwäche.
Also die Nebennieren funktionieren nicht so gut.
Und damit ist so die Hormonsteuerung irgendwie problematisch.
Okay, verstehe.
Okay.
Und haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, ich habe ein Bruder.
Ist der auch gesund?
Nein, leider ist der gar nicht gesund.
Der hat Darmkrebs.
Und ist aber in Behandlung.
Es tut mir leid.
Ja, jetzt habe ich mich net ein paar Fragen.
Schlafen Sie gut oder ausreichend?
Ja, also ich glaube, zurzeit schlafe ich mehr als ausreichend,
ja, weil ich immer so müde bin.
Aber die Schlafqualität ist halt nicht so gut,
weil ich eben immer noch diese Atemaussätze habe.
Da ist das auch ein bisschen Problem, ja.
Alles gut.
Ja, das war es jetzt von meiner Sorge.
Okay.
Haben Sie noch irgendwelche Ergänzung?
Nö, ich glaube, jetzt kann ich mir nichts weiter erzählen.
Okay.
Haben Kollegen andere Fragen?
Haben Sie eine Zeit bemerkt, dass die Nebelstadt unruhe,
konzentration schwer haben?
Konzentrationsschwäche ist ja eigentlich das,
was er auch beschrieben hat, ja.
Er hat es nicht so genannt.
Aber könnte man so beschreiben, ja.
Sind Sie desergen schon bei einem Andreas gewesen?
War ich doch nicht, also ich bin der Tier das erste Mal.
Ähnliche Bescheiden haben Sie?
Vorher?
Ja.
Vorher habe ich solche Bescheiden eigentlich nicht gehabt, nein.
Ich habe Bescheiden, sind langsam Archeite.
Genau, das hat ja auch so geschildert, ja.
Das fing langsam an und wurde immer schlechter.
Das war es.
Können wir anfangen, Archeitschwäche, Mehmet?
Ja, es wäre besser einige Minuten nachher, aber...
Ja, machen wir doch.
Lassen Sie sich doch Zeit.
Machen Sie ruhig in Ruhe und sagen Sie Bescheid,
wenn Sie so weit sind.
Ja, ich glaube, vielen Dank.
Wir laufen ja nicht weg.
Dr. Günth, Sie kennen den Fall, ne?
Ja.
Sie haben den selber gemacht am 15. Januar.
Habe ich hier stehen?
Ja.
Ich habe die Stimmung gefragt.
Stimmung war das nicht.
Stimme war gefragt.
Jemand hat gefragt, ob sich meine Stimme verändert hat.
Das ist natürlich eine Frage, die man selber nicht gut beantworten kann,
weil man seine eigene Stimme ja nicht richtig hört.
Aber der Doktor hat ja eine interessante Frage gestellt.
Er hat ja gefragt, ist Ihrer Frau etwas aufgefallen an Veränderung?
Das fand ich eine super gute Frage.
Ja.
Und gerade in dem Zusammenhang.
Und die hätte vielleicht gesagt, dass sich die Stimme verändert hat,
möglicherweise, keine Ahnung.
Aber ist nicht ausdrücklich erwähnt.
Sie haben gesagt, einige Monate, drei Monate.
Was bedeutet einige Monate?
Ein Monate, drei Monate, fünf Monate.
Also hier ist konkret gesagt drei Monate.
Aber ich denke mal, kein Patient kann das so konkret fassen,
dass er sagt, am Tag X habe ich das das erste Mal gemerkt.
Wann merken Sie, dass sie schlapp sind oder müde sind?
Das schleicht sich ja so an.
Am Anfang nimmt man Symptome nicht ernst, man nimmt sie kaum wahr.
Wenn es dann gar nicht besser wird, dann sagt man mit einem,
das ist doch jetzt schon tagelang, dass ich so müde bin und so schlapp bin.
Und dann irgendwann kommt man dahin, dass man sagt,
das ist doch nicht normal.
Und insofern denke ich mal, dass kein Patient Ihnen das auf den Tag
sagen kann, wie lange so etwas schon ist.
Es ist schon längere Zeit, hier jetzt drei Monate.
Und in der Zeit hat er ja auch seine Gewichtszunahme registriert.
Bitte schön, Mehmet.
Ja, jetzt kann ich versuchen.
Okay, gut.
Guten Abend Frau Obererstin, haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich.
Aber natürlich.
Vielen Dank.
Ich möchte Ihnen über einen neuen Patientin berichten.
Ein 47-jähriger Patient, Herr Glam.
Er hat sich heute bei uns wegen seit drei Monaten allmählich aufgetretenen
Progedierende und bestehende Müdigkeit vorgestellt.
Darüber hinaus klagte er über die
Schwierigkeiten beim Treppen hochgehen und lange Strecke laufen.
Könne lange Strecke laufen, aber nicht schnell wie früher.
Und zusätzlich habe er bemerkt, dass er Gesicht ein bisschen geschwollen
oder der Matthäuser Gesichter habe und der Matthauser Beine habe.
Laut dem Patientin habe er in drei Monaten ca. 4 kg zugenommen.
Der Patient leide an auch Konzentrationstörungen.
Und noch etwas.
Ich habe immer ein kälter Gefühl.
Er friedet.
Er fragte nach Herzklopfen oder Atemproblemen.
Er wurde verneint.
Aber seit ein paar Jahren musste er wegen Schlafabneu ein Gerät atmen.
Ein Atemgerät, kann man auch so sagen, oder?
Ein Atemgerät, das ist wahrscheinlich Zipap oder Zipap.
Er habe Schlafstörungen wegen Abneu.
Und er habe Haut, wahrscheinlich trockene.
Er wird nicht genauso.
Aber ich musste fragen, ob er trockene Haut habe.
Er wird von Hautproblemen.
An am Nese war unabhängig auf Obstipation.
Der Patient hatte ein bisschen geholfen.
Er nahm Asperin bei Bedarf wegen Kopfschmerzen.
Aber das war nicht unabhängig.
Er hat Kopfhaut Probleme, deswegen nutze er bestimmte Shampoo.
Kopfhautprobleme, deswegen nutze er bestimmte Shampoo. Und Raucher, er ist extraucher.
Seit zehn Jahren rauch er nicht mehr. Aber vorher, für 20 Jahre lang, rauch er ein Packier.
Also 20 Packiers. Ja, genau, 20 Packiers. Und er reagiert allergisch gegen Pferdehaare und gegen Diplofenac.
Und die Allergie ersetzt sich als Hauptausschlag exanthin.
Ja, Familie Nanamnese war auch auffällig. Sein Vater habe Adrenaldröseprobleme,
neben ihren Problemen Adrenal-Hormonprobleme. Deswegen nehme er Hormon-Tablete und Mutter sei verstopfen an akutes Herzproblem.
Von einem akuten Herzproblem. Ja, genau. Und sein Bruder, leider, hat Kolonkaschino.
Die anamnestischen Angabe war so. Und die anamnestischen Angaben, vor allem Reinödeme und chronische Mütigkeit, lassen eine Hypertröse vermuten.
Was wäre differenzial diagnostisch noch möglich?
Differenzial diagnostisch, Anämie kann sein oder Vitamin-Mangel kann sein.
Ah, ja. Und was wäre noch denkbar?
Depression kann reingefroren.
Ja, sehr gut.
Gut, was machen Sie mit den Patienten jetzt?
Sollte sich die Verdachsdiagnose bestätigen, werde ich...
Was machen Sie diagnostisch?
Okay, Entschuldigung.
So weiteren Abklärung werde ich den Patienten körpälich ausführlich untersuchen.
Und worauf achten Sie dabei?
Laut- und Beinödeme und Herz, Geräusche und Kopf-H-Enderungen.
Und worauf achten Sie noch?
Die Nagel kann ich auch achten.
Fingernebel, ja.
Im Rahmen der Körper- und Augen.
Ja, ich meine jetzt auch etwas anderes.
Keratokonus als Komplikation kann kommen.
Ich dachte jetzt noch etwas anderes.
Einmal, was erwarten Sie beim Abhorchen des Herz?
Was erwarten Sie da?
Nicht beschleunigt.
Langsamer.
Wir erwarten eine Pradikadie.
Was machen Sie noch?
Ich meine das noch mal bei der reinen Körper- und Untersuchung.
Was Sie mit Ihren Händen machen?
Ja, Turgotonus kann ich kontrollieren.
Ödeme, Beine drücken und die Ödem kontrollieren.
Und die Tendonreflexe kontrollieren.
Die Reflexe? Darauf folgen Sie raus?
Ja, genau.
Was erwarten Sie?
Das ist der langsam reagiert.
Sehr schön.
Was machen Sie da?
Glückbild werde ich veranlassen.
Und TSH und F4, F3
und Sondographie.
Sondographie und Abdomenssonographie.
Was wäre die weiterführende Untersuchung nach der Schilddrüse?
Antithyroglobulin.
Ich kann als Labo-Untersuchung machen.
Und Tiroiz-Zintographie.
Die nächste Stufe nach der Sonnung.
Bei einem Gerichtsprech wird nicht der Patient über Schwälung im
Hals, aber es kann noch kleine Dinge befinden.
Wie machen Sie die Tastuntersuchung von der Schilddrüse?
Ich stehe nach hinten von Patienten.
Ich taste die Schilddrüse und sage schlucken Sie bitte.
Dann kann ich diese Schilddrüse enttasten.
Ja, ganz genau.
Was wäre die Therapie, wenn sich Ihre Diagnose bestätigt?
Als erste Schritt werde ich enttiroxin verschreiben.
Dann kann man eigentlich erwarten, dass es besser geht.
Ja, super.
Das ist alles wie geschmiert gekommen.
Hier sind noch Fragen gewesen.
Das wissen Sie wahrscheinlich, weil es im Schwäbischen sagt man das.
Wie nennt man die Vergrößerung der Schilddrüse?
Ja, genau.
Da haben die Süddeutschen einen Vorteil.
Sie kennen das.
Warum ist es im Süddeutschland mehr?
Ich wusste aber, dass ich daran nicht gut erinnere.
Ein Medaill oder so etwas.
Ja, genau.
Es gibt so einen Halsschmuck.
Das nennt man dann ein Kropfband.
Aber warum ist das Schilddrüsenproblem in Süddeutschland verstärkt?
Einer der Hauptversorger mit Jod sind Sehfische.
Natürlich haben sie im Süddeutschland keine Sehfische zu essen.
Oder hatten früher nicht.
Genau so wie in Nordtürkai.
Eigentlich ist Deutschland ein Jod-Mangel-Gebiet.
Aber wir haben alle schon seit Uhrzeit jodierte Speise-Salz.
Damit ist das Problem in dieser Hinsicht vom Tisch.
Wer sich nicht völlig salzlos ernährt,
kriegt über seine Kochsalzversorgung regelmäßig genug Jod mit.
Dann haben die noch gefragt, was der Vater hat und wie das behandelt wird.
Wissen Sie das zufällig, wie das heißt?
Diese Nebenjähren-Indofficienz?
Addison-Decis.
Addison-Encarpement.
Perfekt.
Genau, Morbind Edison.
Wahnsinn.
Ich kann Sie nicht auf Style hören.
Gelingen wir einfach nicht.
Sie wissen alles.
Okay.
Ich denke, sie haben wirklich schön gefragt.
Sie waren ein netter und auch den Patienten sehr zugewandter Arzt.
Und haben gut nachgefragt, wenn irgendetwas war.
Ich habe mich nicht auf die Begriffe und Stichworte begriffen.
Die Präsentation war jetzt nicht ganz so flüssig.
Aber auf alle Fälle, alle Nachfragen, 100%ig.
Ja, auch richtig verstanden.
Und auch immer die richtigen Wortbegriffe und die richtigen Stichworte.
Es ist alles gekommen.
Also ich wüsste nicht,
ob ich mir das nicht aufmerksam bin.
Was man daran jetzt meckern konnte.
Mir ist auch nicht aufgefallen,
dass es sprachlich irgendwelche eindeutigen
Unklarheiten oder so etwas gab.
War eigentlich alles genauso da, wie es sein muss.
Fast nach Lehrbuch.
Ich glaube, Sie können sehr zufrieden sein.
Und Sie können sehr entspannt ihrer Prüfung entgegen schauen.
Ich hoffe, dass die Prüfer in Stuttgart wahrscheinlich, oder?
Ja, dass sie nette Prüfer haben.
Vielleicht sehen wir uns ja vorher noch mal.
Vielleicht sehen wir uns vorher noch einmal.
Ja, hoffentlich.
Sind ja noch ein paar Wochen hin.